kristen drummond live in our newsroom
now with more on this awesome
national recognition kristin definitely
very awesome sasha there were nearly 2
000 nominations submitted from all 50
states the recording academy and grammy
museum dwindled the list down to
25 semi-finalists and one of those music
teachers is from las vegas
as well as the only educator from nevada
up for this national award
i'm just honored to have gone this far
kim ritzer hits a high note in her
career it was nominated for the music
educator grammy that is put out by the
grammy association
a welcome surprise for the choir
director at green valley high school the
national award recognizes teachers
making a significant and
lasting contribution to music education
while demonstrating a commitment to
keeping music education in schools
i do what i do because i love it i've
always wanted to teach choir that's all
i've ever wanted to do
ritzer has been teaching music for 31
years in the clark county school
district
this is what i see on my side the
pandemic made it her first experience
though
only teaching online we're still singing
in a different way but we're still
singing and making music
adjusting to distance education while
continuing to build the choir program
known to perform around the country
we've sung at carnegie hall
and even saying backup for the rock and
roll band the rolling stones in 2013
during a concert in las vegas
here is ritzer with her class at a
rehearsal before the big day
[Music]
but her lessons and passion for music
education go beyond the classroom she's
shown thousands of students how to find
their voice
and use it to make the world a better
place her principal and students
submitted testimonials hard work
kindness
bravery and enthusiasm are just a few of
the qualities which mrs ritzer exudes on
a daily basis
and helps to instill in all of us all
praise her ability to inspire the next
generation of singers
complementing her dedication to keep the
music playing
even during challenging circumstances
i've built a program there that i'm very
very proud of
10 finalists will be named next month
and a winner will be highlighted during
the 2021 grammy week events
now that winner will receive 10 thousand
dollar cash prize
and a matching grant for their school's
program and sasha
our fingers are crossed for her
absolutely kristen so great